the other thing I wanted to ask you is
you have experience in the stock market
obviously have you been away but have
you done any research or heard anything
about the the senators who were alleged
accused of insider trading right before
the stock market crashed yeah the
Senators were privy to certain hearings
that spook them and they dumped their
shares right and insider trading laws
are very rarely exercised unless they
want to make an example out of someone
like Martha Stewart Ivan Boesky
the law I mean one of the functions of
the law is to protect the interest of
the most powerful people in the world
mm-hmm and that includes the politicians
and the legislators and the business
owners at the top of the pyramid so
you're not gonna see any play in the
legal system going against those guys
for selling their shares I mean my wake
up call was the insider trading the
short selling the purchasing of the put
options before 9/11 happened the bets
came in before 9/11 happened I was an
options trader
I watched him happen couldn't believe it
it was headline news and they said they
were gonna track the trades down and the
only way it could have been done was if
insider knowledge from the terrorists
had to be the terrorists and they've
disciplined out the news and years later
it came out those trades were traced
back to an investment bank that was run
by the CIA and anyone who had any
knowledge of those trades was deputized
which means you can't say anything to
anyone about them or else you'll be
thrown in prison so there are people in
this world who know disasters to come in
and profit from them and it's a sad
state of affairs can you I'm sorry you
just kind of blew my mind can you expand
on that a little bit on the insider
trading before 9/11 yes absolutely
wake-up call to how the world really
works so perhaps I mentioned in the
previous interview that I've been
trading the stock market since I was a
teenager right you did when I was a
teenager I also traded what
called the options market now the
options market allows you to put down a
smallish amount of money and make a huge
percentage return or if you if you bet
is wrong you get wiped out so for
example let's say Walmart says go up 10
percent mm-hmm a Walmart option make up
a hundred percent on that move but you
can also buy an option that will make
money if the stock goes down so if
Walmart goes down 10 percent a Walmart
put option will go up a hundred percent
a put option yeah a call option means
I'm sorry I apologize in advance because
I don't know anything about stock the
stock market okay so if the stock if you
buy stock and it goes up you're gonna
make profits did you buy stock and it
goes down you're gonna lose right well
options allow you to make money either
way if you buy a call option and the
stock goes up you will make hundreds of
percent okay if it goes down you will be
wiped out if you buy a put option and
the stock goes down you will make
hundreds of percent but if it goes up
you will be wiped out Wow
now there is an average daily volume on
these securities and in the week before
9/11 the pot options for the ER lines
the trading on them started to go up 10
times daily over 20 times daily average
until it was just so outstanding
it was making headline news and how many
days before 9/11 was this a week before
9/11 what evidence is there that it
could have been people in the CIA doing
this because it was in the news they
said it was the terrorists they're gonna
trace the trades the trades were traced
and it was traced back to an investment
bank
by CIA oh my god I can't that's hard to
comprehend yeah well if you google it
you all the details are laid out online
and it tells you the name of the
investment company
it tells you the name of the CIA guy the
xgi guy that was running in and how the
you know everybody who had knowledge of
the trades was deputized so they could
never ever speak about those trades
[Laughter]